Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. How to avoid history. No one have ever found a way of avoiding history. It is upon us and around us all. The only thing when you look at the cunning, villainous faces in our class, you wonder if history may not soon be worse than ever. If the hist master go on enough, you begin to believe that death is really upon
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。如何逃避历史。从来没有人找到过逃避历史的方法。它就在我们身上，围绕在我们周围。当你看着班里那些狡猾、邪恶的面孔时，你唯一会想的就是，历史会不会很快变得比以往任何时候都更糟糕。如果历史老师继续讲下去，你就会开始相信死亡真的降临到
you. You have something wrong with your heart which have stopped beating. Your jaw is stuck open and you cannot close it. Also, you're going blind. On the whole, it is better to put up with the hist lesson and draw beetles on the blotch quietly. The wise words of 1950s schoolboy Nigel Molesworth, or rather of his creators, Geoffrey Willans and Ronald Searle. Now, Nigel Molesworth, one of my heroes when I was a child, was not a fan of history or of history lessons or indeed of history books. But writing for children is one of the great challenges, I think, for any writer, no matter what the genre i've been doing it tom you've been writing um books for young adults young adults is basically teenagers is that right so i believe yeah so so i believe yeah so you've got you've got two books coming out this week yeah yes um
你了。你的心脏出了问题，已经停止了跳动。你的下巴僵住了，张着嘴合不上。而且，你快要瞎了。总的来说，忍受历史课并在草稿纸上悄悄画甲虫会更好。这是 20 世纪 50 年代的小学生奈杰尔·莫尔斯沃思（Nigel Molesworth）的名言，或者更确切地说是他的创作者杰弗里·威兰斯（Geoffrey Willans）和罗纳德·塞尔（Ronald Searle）的名言。奈杰尔·莫尔斯沃思是我儿时的偶像之一，他并不喜欢历史、历史课，甚至不喜欢历史书。但我认为，无论什么体裁，为儿童写作对任何作家来说都是巨大的挑战。我一直在做这件事，汤姆，你一直在写青少年读物，青少年基本上就是十几岁的孩子，对吧？我是这么认为的，是的，所以我有两本书这周要出版，是的，嗯
that's the first of july so you've shamelessly shoehorned this into an episode of the podcast. Well, it's an interesting... There's two things to say about this podcast. One, it is pure, shameless, naked self-promotion. And the second is it is actually a genuinely really fascinating topic that even people who have no interest in history, and indeed no children, often have very strong opinions about. How do you tell the story of the past for people in short trousers have no interest in history and indeed no children often have very strong opinions about what how do
那是七月一日，所以你厚颜无耻地把这件事塞进了这期播客里。嗯，这是一个有趣的……关于这个播客有两件事要说。第一，这是纯粹、无耻、赤裸裸的自我推销。第二，这实际上是一个非常迷人的话题，即使是那些对历史毫无兴趣，甚至没有孩子的人，通常也会有非常强烈的看法。你如何为那些穿着短裤、对历史毫无兴趣、甚至没有孩子的人讲述过去的故事？他们通常对……有什么看法？你如何
you tell the story of the past for people you know in short trousers um dominic sandbrook being sincere yeah i am being since well that's just the sincerity and then we can get back to the self-promotion hopefully in um in a second right so i've got i've got actually got the the proofs of your two books that are coming out yes um and And they are on the Second World War and the Six Wives of Henry VIII. Yeah. So you're going straight in. Yeah. With two really obscure little loans.
为那些穿着短裤的孩子讲述过去的故事，嗯，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）在真诚地说话，是的，我是在真诚地……好吧，这就是真诚，然后我们希望能在片刻之后回到自我推销上来。好吧，我实际上已经拿到了你这周要出版的两本书的校样，是的，嗯，它们是关于第二次世界大战和亨利八世的六位妻子的。是的。所以你直接切入主题了。是的。带着两本非常冷门的小书。
Two obscure fields of history there. Because basically people complain, don't they? Nazis and Tudors. Nazis and Tudors. Hitler and Henry. And you've gone for that, presumably. That's what the kids want. Well, I think there's – so, yes, this is a series called Adventures in Time.
两个冷门的历史领域。因为基本上人们会抱怨，不是吗？纳粹和都铎王朝。纳粹和都铎王朝。希特勒和亨利。你大概就是冲着这个去的。这就是孩子们想要的。嗯，我想有——所以，是的，这是一个名为《时间冒险》（Adventures in Time）的系列。
And, yeah, when I first talked about it with the publishers of Penguin, they sort of said, should we do the Nazis and Tudors first? And I thought, yeah, why not? I mean, you're not going to do the Industrial Revolution and the Seven Years' War as you're opening two salvos in a campaign to kind of, you know, share the joys of the past with the nation's youngsters. But they're not just being published in Britain,
而且，是的，当我第一次和企鹅出版社（Penguin）的编辑谈论这件事时，他们说，我们应该先做纳粹和都铎王朝吗？我想，是的，为什么不呢？我的意思是，你不会在向全国青少年分享过去乐趣的运动中，把工业革命和七年战争作为开篇的两部作品。但它们不仅仅是在英国出版，
so that's been quite interesting. For example, the Second World War one is also coming out in Germany. Do you have any changes for that? No, interestingly. The German publishers said, it's very English. But they said... Am I not right? I think you mentioned this to me that you initially began with Hitler in the trench losing his dog. Yes. So the opening of the Second World War one, the first chapter, I was trying to think of a way,
所以这很有趣。例如，关于第二次世界大战的那本也要在德国出版。你有什么改动吗？没有，有趣的是。德国出版商说，这非常英式。但他们说……我没说错吧？我想你跟我提过，你最初是以希特勒在战壕里弄丢了他的狗作为开头的。是的。所以第二次世界大战那本书的开头，第一章，我一直在想办法，
how on earth are you going to tell this story, the Second War, to children who haven't done the First World War, who don't know where all the countries are and all that stuff? And I thought, well, you just start with the protagonist. With the dog. You start with the dog, yeah. You start with Hitler. Like Enid Blyton.
你到底要怎么给那些没学过第一次世界大战、不知道所有国家在哪里以及所有这些东西的孩子讲这个故事，第二次世界大战？我想，好吧，你只要从主角开始就行了。从那条狗开始。从那条狗开始，是的。你从希特勒开始。就像伊妮德·布莱顿（Enid Blyton）一样。
And I start with Hitler as a boy. You know, Hitler as a boy, he goes off to fight in the First World War. His shattering experience that that that sort of poisons his mind Hitler turning to darkness as it were I mean that's quite a familiar trajectory in children's stories and it is the trajectory of Hitler's life obviously I mean we had that two episodes with Ian Kershaw didn't we and he was saying you know there's Hitler's not a monster from the beginning. He's maybe damaged or he's maybe had a traumatic childhood or whatever, but he's not a
我从少年希特勒开始。你知道，少年希特勒，他去参加第一次世界大战。他那破碎的经历，那种毒害他思想的东西，希特勒转向黑暗，可以说，我的意思是，这在儿童故事中是一个相当熟悉的轨迹，而且这显然是希特勒一生的轨迹。我的意思是，我们和伊恩·克肖（Ian Kershaw）做了两期节目，不是吗？他说，你知道，希特勒并不是从一开始就是个怪物。他可能受过伤害，或者可能有一个创伤性的童年什么的，但他并不是
mass murderer straight away. So taking children into that story is interesting. Right. And so you set him up with a dog. He's a guy with a lovable dog. Yeah, but the dog had to go. And I think that then your son, he was eight? Well, he was eight when he read it. Well, he was eight when he read it, yeah. He was eight when he read it. So is Hitler the hero? Yeah.
一开始就是个杀人犯。所以带孩子们进入那个故事很有趣。对。所以你让他带着一条狗出场。他是一个有可爱狗狗的人。是的，但那条狗必须得走。我想然后你儿子，他八岁？嗯，他读的时候八岁。嗯，他读的时候八岁，是的。他读的时候八岁。所以希特勒是英雄吗？是的。
So the way this works, right, I should explain the backstory. So my son's school, they were doing evacuees as their termly topic. So they had a day when they dressed up as evacuees. And only in Britain, of course, would people do this because in any other country it would be such a traumatic experience. Whereas his school, they actually put on a thing where they sang wartime songs. It's just pre-COVID, so it was brilliant.
所以这个运作方式是，好吧，我应该解释一下背景故事。我儿子的学校，他们把“疏散人员”作为学期主题。所以他们有一天打扮成疏散人员。当然，只有在英国人们才会这样做，因为在任何其他国家这都会是一种创伤性的经历。而他的学校，他们实际上举办了一个活动，唱战时歌曲。那是在新冠疫情之前，所以非常棒。
I loved it. But my son complained. He said, well, we don't do enough about tanks or battles. You know, the evacuee stuff is great, but I want to know about the sort of narrative of the war. at half term we took him to the imperial war museum which for people who are not british listeners it's this amazing museum in london yeah full tanks was basically a museum about the world wars and britain's experience of war in the 20th century and after and as we we went around the museum and he was
我很喜欢。但我儿子抱怨说，嗯，我们对坦克或战斗了解得不够多。你知道，疏散人员的东西很棒，但我想要了解战争的叙事。期中假时我们带他去了帝国战争博物馆，对于非英国听众来说，这是伦敦一个很棒的博物馆，是的，满是坦克，基本上是一个关于世界大战和英国在 20 世纪及以后战争经历的博物馆。当我们参观博物馆时，他
quite enthusiastic but in that way that children he started to sort of flag and not i could see he wasn't really reading all the captions and he was just tempted to start climbing on gun barrels and whatever um and i said well if you can go around without climbing on any more weaponry um when we get to the gift shop i'll get you a book on the second world war and there wasn't really there wasn't really the right kind of thing. So they were all kind of Usborne-y books with lots of pictures, or they were horrible histories, but there wasn't a really
相当热情，但以那种孩子们的方式，他开始有点疲惫了，我看得出他并没有真正阅读所有的说明文字，他只是想爬上炮管什么的，嗯，我说，好吧，如果你能不再爬上任何武器，当我们到礼品店时，我会给你买一本关于第二次世界大战的书。但并没有那种合适的书。它们要么是那种有很多图片的奥斯本（Usborne）书，要么是《恐怖历史》（Horrible Histories），但没有一个真正
rollicking narrative. And I said, I'm amazed that Anthony Beaver or Max Hastings or somebody hasn't done... James Holland. James Holland, exactly, hasn't done a kid's history of the Second World War. My brother has done Lady Bird books.
生动有趣的叙事。我说，我很惊讶安东尼·比弗（Anthony Beevor）或马克斯·黑斯廷斯（Max Hastings）或者某个人还没有做……詹姆斯·霍兰德（James Holland）。詹姆斯·霍兰德，没错，还没有做过给孩子看的第二次世界大战历史。我哥哥做过瓢虫丛书（Lady Bird books）。
He's done a Lady Bird book, but those are Lady Bird books. But they're for adults, aren't they? Named for adults, exactly. And I sort of thought, well, you know, there's a whole market. Tom Holland will get in on this if I'm not careful. And I just thought you could – I mentioned it idly to my editor. You know, you could do a whole series of, you call them adventures in time,
他做过一本瓢虫书，但那是瓢虫书。但那是给成年人看的，不是吗？确实是给成年人看的，没错。我当时想，好吧，你知道，有一个完整的市场。如果我不小心，汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）会抢先一步。我只是觉得你可以——我随口向我的编辑提了一下。你知道，你可以做一个完整的系列，你称之为《时间冒险》，
Cleopatra, Alexander the Great, Henry VIII, the Second World War. And, you know, he said, great, do it. So I did. And I got my son to read each chapter as I wrote it and said, basically, tell me what's boring. Tell me what you don't understand. A good example is I had the phrase, in 1929, the world economy tottered
克利奥帕特拉、亚历山大大帝、亨利八世、第二次世界大战。而且，你知道，他说，太棒了，做吧。所以我做了。我让我儿子在我写每一章时都读一遍，并说，基本上，告诉我哪里无聊。告诉我你不明白什么。一个很好的例子是，我用了“1929年，世界经济摇摇欲坠”这个短语，
or something. He said, what's the economy? And I was like, Christ, how do you explain that? The world money system? I mean, it sounds so weak. So I had to think of another way of doing it. And Hitler and his dog was one of the key stumbling points. Because at the point where Hitler has his dog in the trenches, my son said, oh, is he the hero? And I said, no, he's going to turn out to be the villain. He said, well, he can't have a dog. I mean, the hero has a dog. The villain never has a dog.
或者类似的话。他说，什么是经济？我当时想，天哪，你怎么解释这个？世界货币体系？我的意思是，这听起来太无力了。所以我不得不换一种方式来表达。希特勒和他的狗是关键的绊脚石之一。因为在希特勒在战壕里带着他的狗的那一刻，我儿子说，哦，他是英雄吗？我说，不，他后来会变成反派。他说，好吧，他不能有狗。我的意思是，英雄才有狗。反派从来没有狗。
He's right, isn't he? He was right. The dog had to go. I took the dog out. It was tipping the scales too much in Hitler's favour. So the dog had to go. I could have given the dog to Churchill I suppose but I just took the dog out
他说得对，不是吗？他是对的。那条狗必须得走。我把狗去掉了。它让天平太向希特勒倾斜了。所以那条狗必须得走。我想我本可以把狗给丘吉尔，但我只是把狗去掉了。
yeah, well Churchill is a black dog, yeah, it's depression well you very nobly said in your author's note, the first drafts of this book were read and edited by Arthur Sandbrook and Connolly Norman aged 8, so any mistakes are definitely their fault that's good punch them down
是的，好吧，丘吉尔有一条“黑狗”，是的，那是抑郁症。嗯，你在作者注中非常高尚地说，这本书的初稿是由亚瑟·桑德布鲁克（Arthur Sandbrook）和康诺利·诺曼（Connolly Norman）阅读和编辑的，他们当时 8 岁，所以任何错误绝对是他们的错。那很好，把责任推给他们。
you've got to have someone to blame haven't you yeah yeah okay well i think that's enough self-promotion oh no what what we've got i thought we had hours to fill i i think it is but um it's interesting the lack of narrative accounts that you highlighted yeah because we grew up with narrative accounts didn't we i mean um, we've got a question from Jonathan Calder about Lady Bird history books. I mean, they were always pure narrative. So for every British listener, I would imagine, to this podcast will know what we're talking about. But for the overseas listeners, they're small books. What are they?
你得找个人来背锅，不是吗？是的，是的，好吧，我想自我推销已经够多了。哦，不，我们有什么？我以为我们有几个小时要填补。嗯，我想是这样，但……你强调的叙事性记述的缺乏很有趣，是的，因为我们是在叙事性记述中长大的，不是吗？我的意思是，嗯，我们收到了乔纳森·考尔德（Jonathan Calder）关于瓢虫历史书的问题。我的意思是，它们总是纯粹的叙事。所以对于每一位英国听众，我想这个播客的听众都会知道我们在说什么。但对于海外听众，它们是小书。它们是什么？
They're about, I've got a couple of them here. They're 50 pages long. They're little hardbacks. And they're very basic kind of narratives of, I narratives of the ones I've got with me right now, Oliver Cromwell, Warwick the Kingmaker, James I and the Gunpowder Plot. I mean, I owed so much of my understanding of history as a boy to those books. Didn't you? Were you a big Lady Bird fan?
它们大约是，我这里有几本。它们有 50 页长。它们是小精装书。它们是非常基础的叙事，我手头上的那些，奥利弗·克伦威尔（Oliver Cromwell）、沃里克伯爵“造王者”（Warwick the Kingmaker）、詹姆斯一世和火药阴谋。我的意思是，我作为一个男孩对历史的理解很大程度上归功于那些书。你呢？你是瓢虫书的忠实粉丝吗？
Less so. What? To be honest. I'm stunned by that so the book the book that i really loved uh was the one that i i when i put up um a tweet asking for um questions on this topic and to illustrate it i put up um an illustration of my favorite book as a child history book which was um a history of the world by a guy called Plantagenet Somerset Frye did you ever come across him no no I you mentioned it and I'd never heard of this okay so he wasn't actually called Plantagenet he was called Peter okay he was called Plantagenet because he was a big fan of Richard III oh he's a Ricardian
没那么喜欢。什么？老实说。我对此感到震惊。所以那本书，我真正喜欢的书，是当我发推文询问关于这个话题的问题时，为了说明这一点，我放了一张我儿时最喜欢的历史书的插图，那是一本由一个叫普兰塔吉内·萨默塞特·弗莱（Plantagenet Somerset Frye）的人写的世界史，你见过他吗？不，不，你提到了，我从来没听说过。好吧，所以他实际上不叫普兰塔吉内，他叫彼得。好吧，他叫普兰塔吉内是因为他是理查三世的忠实粉丝。哦，他是个理查派（Ricardian）。
okay well eccentric position when he was writing i guess yeah in the 60s and 70s um and he he was he was a brilliant guy because i i didn't know this when i um when i read it as a child but he um he was a kind of famous dandy at university he had a cape and a gold top cane um he was Thorpe. He was a founding member of the Liberal Democrats. Talking Jeremy Thorpe. So there was a Jeremy Thorpe thing going on. Yeah, there was a Jeremy Thorpe connection. And each year in the Times, he would put in, on the 15th of March,
好吧，我想他在写作时是一个古怪的立场，是的，在 60 年代和 70 年代，嗯，他是一个天才，因为我当时不知道这一点，当我儿时读它的时候，但他是一个大学里的著名花花公子，他有一件斗篷和一根金顶手杖，他是索普（Thorpe）。他是自由民主党的创始成员。说的是杰里米·索普（Jeremy Thorpe）。所以当时有杰里米·索普的事情。是的，有杰里米·索普的联系。每年在《泰晤士报》上，他都会在 3 月 15 日，
he would put in a little note commemorating the death of Julius Caesar. What? And the reason that I liked him. Oh, and also, he won a jackpot on a TV quiz show. What was the Huey Green one? There was... W Money. W Money, yeah.
放一个小条子纪念尤利乌斯·凯撒（Julius Caesar）的逝世。什么？这就是我喜欢他的原因。哦，还有，他在一个电视问答节目中赢得了大奖。休伊·格林（Huey Green）的那个是什么？有……W Money。W Money，是的。
So he won lots of money on that. So he was a kind of interesting guy. But his real interest was ancient history. Okay. And the reason that I liked his history of the world was that rather than focusing on all the stuff that the Lady Bird books focused on, which was specifically British history, he majored on things like Samaria
所以他在那上面赢了很多钱。所以他是一个有趣的人。但他真正的兴趣是古代史。好吧。我喜欢他的世界史的原因是，他没有专注于瓢虫书所关注的所有东西，也就是专门的英国历史，他主攻像苏美尔
and the New Kingdom and medieval China and all kinds of weird stuff like that and had fabulous illustrations. And basically, he focused on the Roman Empire. Yeah, who doesn't like the Romans? They were amazing. I can still, just sitting here, I can visualise them. There's one of Nero looking out at Rome on fire. There's one of the Roman soldiers looking up at Jesus on the cross.
和新王国、中世纪中国以及各种奇怪的东西，而且有很棒的插图。基本上，他专注于罗马帝国。是的，谁不喜欢罗马人呢？他们太棒了。我坐在这里，仍然能想象出它们。有一张尼禄看着罗马着火的图。有一张罗马士兵抬头看着十字架上的耶稣的图。
There's a battle between the Romans and the Gauls. Absolutely loved it. There's the Sassanian king capturing the Roman emperor. Fabulous stuff. And that's really what I loved. And I thought that the Lady Bird books were a bit embarrassing. Embarrassing? Why embarrassing?
有一场罗马人和高卢人之间的战斗。绝对喜欢它。还有萨珊国王俘虏罗马皇帝的图。太棒了。这确实是我所喜欢的。我觉得瓢虫书有点尴尬。尴尬？为什么尴尬？
A little bit. Why were you embarrassed by the Lady Bird books? This is deranged. I felt slightly talked down to by them. I tell you what, I've picked a couple of my favourite bits out, actually. James I and the Gunpowder Plot. I like the strong views. King James was not a pleasant man.
有一点。你为什么对瓢虫书感到尴尬？这太疯狂了。我觉得它们有点居高临下。我告诉你，我实际上挑出了我最喜欢的几段。詹姆斯一世和火药阴谋。我喜欢强烈的观点。詹姆斯国王不是一个讨人喜欢的人。
Not only was he of ungainly appearance, he was also untrustworthy and deceitful. His lubberly, ungainly appearance, added to prejudice against the Scots, made him unwelcome. So she's very... L. Dugard Peach is the author of this. It's very down on James I. But do you know what he said about Guy Fawkes? He said, Guy Fawkes, he has Guy Fawkes being killed.
他不仅外表笨拙，而且不可信、虚伪。他那笨拙、难看的外表，加上对苏格兰人的偏见，使他不受欢迎。所以她非常……L. 杜加德·皮奇（L. Dugard Peach）是这本书的作者。她非常看不起詹姆斯一世。但你知道她是怎么评价盖伊·福克斯（Guy Fawkes）的吗？她说，盖伊·福克斯，她写盖伊·福克斯被杀了。
And then he says, thus died a man whose name has quite wrongly or mistakenly come to mean anyone of queer or foolish appearance. Guy or Guy Fawkes was neither. He was a brave man and a gentleman, a faithful friend to the limit of endurance, ready to die for the faith in which he believed. You must love that. Okay, well, but I think when I, because I was reading them in the 70s, I think even then they felt old fashioned. Oh, no, I think this is deranged. I think I loved the pure narrative elements of them. And I think, so that to me, I think there are two reasons
然后她说，就这样，一个名字被错误地或误解地用来指代任何外表古怪或愚蠢的人的人死了。盖伊或盖伊·福克斯两者都不是。他是一个勇敢的人和绅士，是一个忠诚的朋友，直到忍耐的极限，准备为他所信仰的信仰而死。你一定喜欢这个。好吧，但我认为当我，因为我在 70 年代读它们时，我想即使在那时它们也感觉过时了。哦，不，我认为这太疯狂了。我认为我喜欢它们纯粹的叙事元素。而且我认为，所以对我来说，我认为有两个原因
that children get interested in history. One of them is the fascination of the very unfamiliar, the sort of curiosity about the strange and exotic worlds, you know, that you just talked about with the ancient world. Completely. And the other thing is the story, is pure story. And one of the reasons I think I like the Lady Bird books was that Lady Bird didn't only do history,
孩子们对历史感兴趣。其中之一是对非常不熟悉的事物的迷恋，那种对奇怪和异国情调世界的好奇心，你知道，你刚才谈到的古代世界。完全是。另一件事是故事，是纯粹的故事。我认为我喜欢瓢虫书的原因之一是，瓢虫不仅做历史，
they also did books about Robin Hood and King Arthur, who were my real passions when I was about five or six. And Peter and Jane. Well, they did do Peter and Jane. John and Jane. It was Peter and Jane. My dog is sick. My dog is dead.
他们还做关于罗宾汉和亚瑟王的书，那是我五六岁时真正的热情所在。还有彼得和简（Peter and Jane）。嗯，他们确实做了彼得和简。约翰和简。那是彼得和简。我的狗病了。我的狗死了。
All right, all right, Mr. Cynic. So they did that. They did the King Arthur and Robin Hood. And to me, I didn't really distinguish between the stories of King Arthur, let's say, and the story of Oliver Cromwell or James I or something. And I think to get children interested in history, it has to be about the story. There has to be a sense of narrative drama, of jeopardy, of character. Do you know what it is?
好了，好了，愤世嫉俗先生。所以他们做了那个。他们做了亚瑟王和罗宾汉。对我来说，我并没有真正区分亚瑟王的故事，比如说，和奥利弗·克伦威尔或詹姆斯一世的故事。我认为要让孩子们对历史感兴趣，它必须是关于故事的。必须有一种叙事戏剧感、危机感、人物感。你知道那是什么吗？
Yeah. I'm thinking about it, what I resented about the Lady Bird books. So they did one on Julius Caesar and the conquest of Britain. Julius Caesar and Roman Britain, yeah. Julius Caesar and Roman Britain. And I thought it was going to be about Julius Caesar. Yeah. And actually, a lot of it was about Roman Britain.
是的。我在想，我对瓢虫书感到不满的是什么。所以他们做了一本关于尤利乌斯·凯撒和征服英国的书。尤利乌斯·凯撒和罗马不列颠，是的。尤利乌斯·凯撒和罗马不列颠。我以为它是关于尤利乌斯·凯撒的。是的。实际上，很多内容是关于罗马不列颠的。
It was. And it was all about them building roads and things. Villas. I didn't want that. I wanted Julius Caesar. I think you can do a bit of both, though, Tom. No, I was disappointed. And I felt that I'd been sold, you dodgy goods dodgy goods i think there is quite a lot of riding
确实。而且全是关于他们修路之类的事情。别墅。我不想要那个。我想要尤利乌斯·凯撒。但我认为你可以两者兼顾，汤姆。不，我很失望。我觉得我被卖了，你卖的是劣质商品，劣质商品，我认为有很多骑马
across harsh terrain in that that particular book there's not enough about stabbings in the senate chamber yes which is what you're after so you then wrote your own book on that basically basically yeah rubicon but what i remember is um that there were huge there were kind of huge narrative histories of Greece and Rome in the local library that I just I don't think they would exist now. I can't find them. No, but I think there was an appetite for them. I mean, I was
穿过崎岖地形的内容，在那本书里，关于元老院刺杀的内容不够多，是的，这才是你想要的。所以你后来基本上写了你自己的书，关于那个，基本上是的，卢比孔河（Rubicon），但我记得的是，嗯，当地图书馆里有巨大的关于希腊和罗马的叙事历史，我只是不认为它们现在还会存在。我找不到它们。不，但我认为当时对它们有需求。我的意思是，我
kind of really struck while writing my books and trying bits on children that maybe because they were just coerced or because I was bribing them, children generally said, who read them said they liked the story, they liked the sense of tension. I think you have to have, if you give them kids' characters, I mean, think about the appeal of Star Wars or The Hobbit
在写我的书并尝试给孩子们看时，真的感到很震惊，也许因为他们只是被强迫的，或者因为我在贿赂他们，读过这些书的孩子们通常说他们喜欢这个故事，他们喜欢那种紧张感。我认为你必须有，如果你给他们孩子角色，我的意思是，想想《星球大战》或《霍比特人》
or Harry Potter to children. I mean, what they like are strong characters, well-defined. They can cope with a little bit of nuance, actually. It doesn't have to be incredibly simplistic. But a sense of urgency, a sense of pace in the narrative. I mean, actually, the weird thing is, I think, Tom, is that all those things are virtues of adult
或《哈利·波特》对孩子的吸引力。我的意思是，他们喜欢的是性格鲜明的人物。他们实际上可以应付一点细微差别。它不必非常简单。但有一种紧迫感，叙事节奏感。我的意思是，实际上，奇怪的是，汤姆，我认为所有这些都是成人叙事历史的优点。所以从某种意义上说，为孩子讲述历史并不是一个太不同的练习。而且，他们喜欢事实。嗯，他们喜欢事实。因为我知道我喜欢。他们可以分享，是的，奇怪的事实。
narrative histories. So in a way, it's not that different an exercise telling history for children. Also, they like facts. Well, they like facts. Because I know I did. They can share, yeah, weird facts.
所以这是一个很好的例子。好吧。在我做的亨利八世那本书里，我和编辑们不断讨论关于令人反感的细节。关于人们的头被砍掉，以及这到底是怎么做的。我们后来有一个事实，当亨利变得非常胖时，关于他如何把一根涂了油的管子塞进他的屁股。他被灌了蜂蜜之类的灌肠剂，
So here's a good example. Okay. In the Henry VIII book that I did, I had constant discussions with the editors about squeamish details. So about people's heads being cut off and exactly how that was done. And we had a fact there later on when Henry's enormously fat about how he has this greased tube pushed up his bottom. And he's given these enemas of like honey and all this kind of
所有这些东西都是为了试图缓解他的痔疮和巨大的肥胖。这只会让他比以往任何时候都更暴躁。我的编辑，他绝不是一个容易感到恶心的人，他说，我不知道这对孩子来说是不是有点过分了，实际上，你知道，所有这些关于灌肠的事情。我把这个给大约四五个孩子看，问他们觉得怎么样。他们说，嗯，你知道，这基本上是整本书里最好的部分。而且我认为孩子们喜欢这些小小的、
thing to try and ease his piles and his enormous obesity. And it just makes him more bad tempered than ever. And my editor, who's not by any means a squeamish man, said, I wonder if this is a bit much for children, actually, you know, all this stuff about the enemas. And I gave this to about four or five children and said, what do you think? And they said, well, you know, this is basically the best bit in the whole book. And I think children love these kind of little,
好奇的细节。为什么是《恐怖历史》？所以《恐怖历史》围绕着，它充满了各种灌肠。全是，是的，基本上是灌肠、灌肠和处决，不是吗？人们用便便做的有趣的事情，是的，所以《恐怖历史》，《恐怖历史》里没有叙事，它是一系列好奇事实的汇编，你是对的，我认为孩子们喜欢好奇的事实，但我认为他们也确实喜欢一点戏剧性。所以我认为我试图做的是将这两件事结合起来。
curious kind of details. Why horrible histories? So horrible histories revolves, it's full of kind of enemas. It's all, yeah, it's enemas, enemas and execas and executions basically isn't it it's amusing ways that people amusing amusing stuff that people have done with poo yeah so horrible histories there's no narrative in horrible histories no it's a compilation of kind of curious facts and you're right i think kids like curious facts but i think they also they do like a bit of drama. And so I suppose what I tried to do was to combine those two things.
因为我记得，显然，基本上，我只对古代的东西感兴趣。所以我也会读现代的东西，但稍微有点勉强。有一个叫彼得·康诺利（Peter Connolly）的人写了一系列书，他是一位出色的插画家，也是一位非常非常严肃的古代军事历史学家，他写了一本书叫《罗马军队》，然后精彩地写了《希腊军队》，他还写了一本关于汉尼拔和迦太基人的书，它结合了，嗯，他会做一点，所以他会在顶部讲述希腊和罗马历史各个时期的故事。然后他会给你很多关于武器的事实。然后他会做很棒的插图，
Because I remember, obviously, basically, I was only interested in ancient stuff. So I would read modern stuff, but slightly under-sufferance. And there were a series of books by a guy called Peter Connolly, who was a brilliant illustrator and a very very serious historian of of um the ancient military and he did a book called the roman army and then brilliantly the greek army and he did one on hannibal and the carthaginians and it combined um he he would do little so he'd tell the stories of various um periods of greek and roman history at the top. And then he'd give you lots and lots of facts about weaponry. And then he'd do great illustrations,
包括人们被长矛刺伤。对我来说，这种组合是一个完全的赢家。那种获得大量事实和精美插图的感觉，我也喜欢。但这提出了一个关于暴力的非常有趣的问题，不是吗，汤姆？所以我们收到了劳伦·马尔科维奇（Lauren Markovich）关于这个的问题。我会读给你听整个问题，因为有两条推文。这很有趣。
including people being stabbed with spears. And the combination for me was a complete winner. And that kind of sense of getting a lot of facts with great illustrations, I also like that. But that raises a really interesting question about violence, doesn't it, Tom? So we had a question from Lauren Markovich about this. I'll read you the whole question because there were two tweets. And it's quite an interesting one.
她说，我儿子小时候是个贪婪的读者，对历史着迷且有着无法满足的好奇心。协商什么对他来说是合适的，关于种族灭绝、酷刑、战争等，是具有挑战性的。我想我们以某种方式设法解决了，但学校打来过几次电话。我们不想粉饰或混淆，他的提问方式是无情的。所以虽然父母可以了解他们的孩子并以某种程度的成功解决这个问题，但当你为更广泛的儿童读者写作历史时，一个人该如何处理这个问题？我的意思是，我想好吧，所以这是给你的问题，因为显然你必须包括大屠杀，你写过第二次世界大战，是的，所以你是怎么处理的？嗯，那是一个非常……所以其他的
She says, my son was a voracious reader as a child, fascinated and insatiably curious about history. Negotiating what was appropriate for him, re-genocide, torture, warfare, etc., was challenging. I think we managed to navigate our way somehow, but there were a few calls from the school. We didn't want to sugarcoat or obfuscate, and his line of questioning was relentless. So while a parent can read their child and sort this out with some degree of success, but when you're writing history for a broader child audience, how does one approach this i mean i think okay so that's the question for you because obviously you have to include the holocaust you've written about the second world war yeah how so how do you deal with that well that was a really so the other the
第二次世界大战中的东西我觉得是可行的，但大屠杀是一个更困难的问题，我想有，在那一章，大屠杀那一章，必须有一整章。我真的有三种策略。一种是……我的意思是，顺便说一句，写这些书的一大好处是……我的意思是，我们谈论的是 8 到 12 岁的孩子。
other stuff in the second war i felt was kind of doable but the holocaust was a much more difficult question and i thought there were there In that, the Holocaust chapter, there had to be a whole chapter on it. And I had sort of three strategies, really. One was to... I mean, one of the great things, by the way, writing these books for a very... I mean, we're talking about children 8 to 12.
所以这通常是他们第一次遇到这些故事。所以我可以讲故事，而不必担心它们会成为陈词滥调。好吧，它们是陈词滥调，但不会担心孩子们会认出它们，因为这可能是他们第一次遇到它们。所以我对我的编辑说，好吧，我应该避开安妮·弗兰克（Anne Frank）吗？他说，不，不写安妮·弗兰克太疯狂了。她是……这是一个如此伟大的故事。所以整章都是围绕安妮·弗兰克的经历展开的。但在那之内，我做的另外两件事是，
So often it's the very first time they encounter these stories. So I could tell stories without any fear that they would be kind of cliche. Well, they are cliches, but there wouldn't be any fear that children would recognize them as such because it might be the first time they've encountered them. So I said to my editor, well, should I shy away from Anne Frank? And he said, no, it's mad to not to do Anne Frank. She's the it's such a great story. So the whole chapter is framed around Anne Frank's experience. But within that, the two other things I did were,
一个是给出概述。我认为要做到这一点，谈论奥斯威辛集中营等等，对孩子来说，唯一的方法就是完全直白地去做。而且，你知道，不要沉溺于那种暴力的色情，不要不必要地牵动心弦，因为那看起来只是剥削性的和不必要的。我认为你可以非常平淡地陈述事实。
one is to give the overview. And I think the only way to do that and to talk about Auschwitz and so on is to do it complete for children, is to just do it completely starkly. And, you know, not to indulge in the kind of pornography of violence, not to kind of tug the heartstrings unnecessarily, because that just seems exploitative and unnecessary. I think you can just tell the facts very plainly.
这就是发生的事情。这就是有多少人死亡。你知道，这是一个极其黑暗和邪恶的篇章。但我认为你不需要以一种，以一种，正如我所说的，
This is what happened. This is how many people died. You know, it's incredibly dark and evil chapter. But I don't think you need to kind of take the children into the gas chambers kind of in a sort of, in a sort of, as I say,
剥削性的方式把孩子们带进毒气室。但我认为引入的另一种有趣的方式是，它不必——我的意思是，显然，这是一个极其黑暗和令人痛苦的历史篇章，但正如人们所说，其中有光芒。所以我做了，例如，拯救犹太人的故事，那种奥斯卡·辛德勒（Oskar Schindler）类型的故事，或者股票经纪人尼古拉斯·温顿（Nicholas Winton），他把很多孩子带到了英国，但我还告诉他们，那是那个有着惊人
an exploitative way. But the other way I thought it would be an interesting thing to bring in would be it doesn't have to – I mean, obviously, it's an incredibly dark and distressing chapter of history, but there are, as it were, chinks of light within it. So I did, for example, the stories of people who saved Jews, the kind of Oskar Schindler type stories or nicholas winton the stockbroker um who who got lots of um children out to britain um but i also told them that's the one with that amazing
那是《这就是生活》（That's Life），那是《这就是生活》，周围所有的人原来都是他救出的孩子，是的，实际上，如果有人没看过那个，一定要看。这真的很催泪。所以他们把他带到节目上，是的，我不会剧透，但如果你搜索尼古拉斯·温顿，你可以在 YouTube 上找到它。
that's life that's life with all the people around him who turn out to be the children that he'd rescued yeah and actually so if anyone's not seen that, do, do. It's a real tearjerker. So they bring him onto the show and yeah, I won't spoil it, but you can find it on YouTube if you search for Nicholas Winton.
但我发现的另一个故事实际上也是真正的催泪弹，我在写它时感到极其感动，是关于丹麦发生的事情的故事，关于基本上丹麦绝大多数犹太人口，他们被隐藏起来了。有一个小的犹太人口，但他们被邻居隐藏起来了。然后他们被用渔船等方式偷运到瑞典。我记得去过大屠杀博物馆，可能是在华盛顿。
But the other story that I also find actually real tearjerker, and I found incredibly moving writing it, is the story about what happened in Denmark, about how basically the vast majority of Denmark's Jewish population, they were hidden. There was a's Jewish population, they were hidden. There was a small population, but they were hidden by their neighbours. And then they were smuggled to Sweden in kind of fishing boats and so on. I remember going to the Holocaust Museum in maybe Washington.
我想一定是在华盛顿。这是我在整个博物馆里唯一真正哭过的地方，因为其余时间我只是感到，你知道，被它麻木了，被它淹没了，被它震惊了。而且，因为，他们展示了其中一艘船，他们在墙上挂了其中一艘把难民带过海的船。而且因为它是关于人们做好事，突然你感到被许可了。是的。是的。我完全，突然你感到被许可了。是的。
I think it must have been Washington. And it was the only time I actually cried in the whole museum because the rest of the time I just felt, you know, deadened by it, overwhelmed by it, stunned by it. And that, because, and they showed one of the boats, they had one of the boats on the wall that had taken the refugees across to, across the sea. And because it was about people doing good, suddenly you felt licensed. Yeah. Yeah. I totally, suddenly you felt licensed. Yeah.
是的。我完全，我完全同意这一点。所以我把它放进去了，当我写它的时候，你知道，把这个故事浓缩成 800 字左右，并找到一两个可以讲述它的人物。有一个故事，
Yeah. I totally, I totally buy that. So I put that in and while I was writing it, you know, condensing this story into kind of 800 words or something and finding one or two characters who could tell it. And there's a story,
是一个学生，我想他叫威廉·林特（Wilhelm Lindt），他发现了一个，在人群向码头移动的巨大运动中。有一个女孩和她的父母分开了，像一个小女孩，她在哭。他把她放在自行车的车把上，骑到码头，让她和父母团聚，他们把她送上船，她就去了瑞典。这是一个极其令人振奋和感人的故事。他自己说，当船开走时他在哭，他不知道他是因为他们救了这么多人而哭，
it's a student, I think his name is Wilhelm Lindt and he finds a, in the great movement of the crowd towards the quay. There's a girl who's separated from her parents, like a little girl, and she's crying. And he puts her on the handlebars of his bike, and he rides down to the quay and reunites with her parents, and they put her on the boat, and off she goes to Sweden. And it's an incredibly heartening and moving story. And he says himself, he was crying as the boat pulled away and he didn't know whether he was crying that they got so many people out
还是因为羞愧而哭，因为这竟然发生了。而且我认为，你知道，这些是留在人们脑海中的故事。实际上，让孩子们对历史感兴趣的很大一部分是通过这些个人的时刻，不是吗？好吧，我想我们应该在这一点上休息一下。当我们回来时，也许我们可以再次审视暴力的问题，
or whether he was crying with shame almost that this was happening at all. And I think, you know, those are the kinds of stories that stick in people's minds. And actually so much about getting children interested in history is through these individual moments, isn't it? Okay, well, I think we should have a break at this point. When we come back, perhaps we could look again at the issue of violence,
我想孩子们，也许特别是小男孩，特别热衷于此，我知道我曾经是，并看看那个问题。所以我们几分钟后回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、
which I guess children, maybe particularly little boys, particularly keen on, I know that I was, and look at that question. So we'll be back in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news,
评论、一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。
reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在谈论儿童历史。在休息之前，我们正在谈论，嗯，多米尼克写了一本关于第二次世界大战的书，我们正在谈论你如何为孩子写像大屠杀这样可怕和怪异的事情。但我猜第二次世界大战是一个原始主题的原因之一是因为它太近了。是的。所以我提到了普兰塔吉内·萨默塞特·弗莱的书，其中有一个序列，正如我所说，罗马人与高卢人战斗。我喜欢那个，因为它与《阿斯泰利克斯》（Asterix）相匹配，那是罗马占领高卢的。而且显然有回声
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking history for children. And before the break, we were talking about, well, Dominic's written a book on Second World War, and we were talking about how do you write about something as terrible and monstrous as the Holocaust for children. But I guess one of the reasons why the Second World War is a raw subject is because it is so close. Yeah. So I mentioned the Plantagenet-Somerset Frye book, and there's a sequence in that, as I said, of the Romans fighting the Gauls. And I like that because it matched up with Asterix, which was one of Roman occupation of Gaul. And there are clearly echoes
纳粹占领法国的。当时，我根本不知道这与此有关。但它也借鉴了高卢在罗马征服它时所经历的历史经验。在《阿斯泰利克斯》中，没有人死亡。最糟糕的事情是有人可能会带着星星在头上绕着树结束。但当然，现实是，根据普鲁塔克（Plutarch）的说法，凯撒杀了一百万高卢人，又奴役了一百万。老实说，在我童年的大部分时间里，我完全不知道这一点。而且我认为我小时候喜欢古代历史的原因之一是觉得它既非常、非常令人兴奋和迷人，又遥远且疏离。我认为恐龙也是如此，我对恐龙的迷恋，它们迷人而可怕。我不想和霸王龙在一起，但我永远不会和霸王龙在一起，因为它们灭绝了。同样地，我可以为彼得·康诺利这些惊人的画作的奇观而感到兴奋。他做了一个
there of the Nazi occupation of France. At the time, I had no idea that these play was being made with that. But it is also drawing on the historical experience that Gaul underwent when the Romans conquered it. And in Asterix, nobody dies. The worst that happens is that somebody might end up in a tree with stars going around the head. But of course, the reality is, according to Plutarch, Caesar killed a million Gauls and enslaved another million. And to be honest, for most of my childhood, I was completely oblivious to that. And I think that one of the reasons why I enjoyed ancient history as a child was the feeling that it was simultaneously very, very exciting and glamorous and distant and removed. And I think the same is true with dinosaurs, my fascination with dinosaurs, that they were glamorous and terrifying. And I wouldn't want to be with a Tyrannosaur, but I would never be with a Tyrannosaur because they were extinct. And in the same way, I could kind of thrill to the spectacle of these amazing drawings by Peter Connolly. He did a
精彩的亚历山大跨越格拉尼库斯河（Granicus）的插图，以及斯巴达人在温泉关（Thermopylae）和萨拉米斯战役（Battle of Salamis）等的插图。这很令人兴奋，因为这太遥远了，我真正要处理的只是它的魅力。而且我认为，我不知道这是否是你曾经经历过的，但思考它，我认为它确实为我解释了为什么古代历史和中世纪历史对我的想象力有特殊的吸引力。现在当我作为一个成年人写它时，为什么我觉得传达它的残酷性以及人们确实死亡的事实如此重要。它不像《阿斯泰利克斯》。人们遭受了可怕的痛苦。
fabulous illustration of Alexander crossing the Granicus and of the Spartans at Thermopylae and Battle of Salamis and so on. And it was thrilling because this was so distant that all I really had to deal with was the glamour of it. And I think that that, I don't know whether that was something that you felt ever experienced, but thinking about it, I think it really explains for me why ancient history and medieval history had a particular purchase on my imagination. And now when I write about it as an adult, why I feel it's so important to convey actually a sense of the brutality of it and the fact that people did die. It wasn't like asterisks. People suffered horribly.
我认为这是一个绝对迷人的问题。在某些方面，我们有点偏离了儿童小说的议题，因为我绝对同意你的观点，我认为我们的同情心或共情心或任何东西上有一种奇怪的诉讼时效。所以我认为这很迷人，你知道，
I think this is an absolutely fascinating question. In some ways, we're kind of spiralling away from the issue of children's fiction because I absolutely agree with you that I think there's a kind of a strange statute of limitations almost on our sympathy or empathy or whatever. So I think it is fascinating how, you know,
20 世纪的一场暴行，即使是死亡人数不是特别高的一场，也会从我们这里呼唤出巨大的怜悯储备。但是，你知道，你会读到，我不知道，巴西尔“保加利亚人屠夫”（Basil the Bulgar Slayer）什么的。但你不读关于他的，是吗？杀很多人。但你读关于……
an atrocity in the 20th century, even one where the death toll is not especially high, will call forth enormous reserves of kind of pity from us. But, you know, you'll read about, I don't know, Basil the Bulgar Slayer or something. But you don't read about him, do you? Killing loads of people. But you read about...
但尤利乌斯·凯撒你读，或者亚历山大大帝。所以有一本关于亚历山大大帝的瓢虫书。不，但我是说作为一个成年人，甚至人们也会这样做。作为一个成年人。是的。我的意思是，我不认为它实际上有什么不同，你看。现在，对于一个孩子，对于一个孩子更是如此。一个孩子，你会读到战斗的记述，战斗和，嗯，你知道，暗杀之类的事情，
But Julius Caesar you do, or Alexander the Great. So there was a Lady Bird book on Alexander the Great. No, but I'm saying as an adult, even people do this. As an adult. Yeah. I mean, I don't think it's actually that different, you see. Now, for a child, for a child even more so. A child, you'll read accounts of battles battles and um you know assassinations and things
而且，因为你是对的，这一切都发生在一层之外，如果它发生得越远，你就越有可能把它看作纯粹的故事书内容，而不会以任何方式感到困扰。我的意思是，我认为这对于儿童故事更普遍，历史与否，我的意思是，如果你看一部《星球大战》电影，有多少人死亡？你知道，我的意思是，死星上有多少人死亡？或者，你知道，在托尔金（Tolkien）的作品中，战斗中有多少人被杀？你感到一种巨大的……婴儿兽人发生了什么？
and and because you're right it all happens at one remove and if it happened the further back it happens the less likely the more likely you are to see it as purely the stuff of a storybook and not to feel troubled by it in any way i mean that's true i think of children's stories more generally history or not i mean if you watch a Star Wars film, how many people die? You know, I mean, how many people died on the Death Star? Or, you know, in Tolkien, how many people are killed in the battles? Do you feel a great sense of... What happens to the baby orcs?
是的，好吧，完全正确。我的意思是，孩子们……孩子们，我的意思是，特别是小男孩，我的意思是，人们可以争论它是否正确或任何东西，那是整个播客系列本身的主题。但他们享受大量的暴力。我的意思是，你真的不需要看操场上的男孩就知道有那种冲动。
Yeah, well, exactly. I mean, do children... Children, I mean, especially little boys, I mean, people can argue about whether it's right or whatever, and that's the subject for a whole podcast series in itself. But they enjoy an awful lot of violence. I mean, you didn't really have to watch boys in their playground to know that there is that urge.
没错，确实如此。我的意思是，孩子们……尤其是小男孩，人们可能会争论这是否正确，但这本身就是一个完整的播客系列的主题。但他们确实非常喜欢暴力。我的意思是，你其实根本不需要去操场观察男孩们，就能知道这种冲动是存在的。
And I think it'd be weird not to, well, we live in a human world, not a perfect world. But I think there's a further kind of shifting of the kaleidoscope on that, Weird, not, well, we live in a human world, not a perfect world. But I think there's a further kind of shifting of the kaleidoscope on that, both between childhood and adulthood, but also changing perspectives from certainly when I was a child and now. And we've got two questions, one from Roman Mihar, who says, what do you think the future of children's histories will be post-woke? The older children's histories are amazing for their breadth and width, but will this survive a focus on the lives of each
我觉得如果不这样做会很奇怪，毕竟我们生活在人类世界，而不是一个完美的世界。但我认为在这一点上，万花筒发生了进一步的转动，不仅是在童年和成年之间，而且视角也发生了变化，肯定和我小时候以及现在相比是这样。我们有两个问题，一个来自Roman Mihar，他问：你认为“觉醒文化”之后儿童历史的未来会怎样？老一辈的儿童历史书在广度和宽度上都很棒，但这种关注每个弱势群体及其生活经历等的做法能持续下去吗？
disadvantaged group and their lived experience, et cetera? And then from Richard Goldstein, what do children teach adults about history? When I refer to Indians, my son retorts they're only called Indians because Columbus thought he was in India. I found myself less hostile to the revision Native American when advocated by a 14 year old and I guess that um so I was reading about the Lady Bird books in preparation for this yeah and apparently um even in uh the 1970s um for instance there's one on Walter Raleigh. And in 1957, you see him launching an attack on people in, I guess, El Dorado or whatever. The Orinoco, wasn't it? He went up, I think. And the perspective you're given in the illustration is of Raleigh. And then this
然后是Richard Goldstein的问题：孩子们能教给成年人关于历史的什么？当我提到“印第安人”时，我儿子反驳说，他们之所以被称为印第安人，只是因为哥伦布以为自己到了印度。我发现当一个14岁的孩子提倡使用“美洲原住民”这个修正后的称呼时，我没那么抵触了。我想，我在准备这期节目时读了《瓢虫丛书》（Lady Bird books），是的，显然即使在20世纪70年代，比如有一本关于沃尔特·雷利的书。在1957年的版本里，你看到他在攻击埃尔多拉多或其他什么地方的人。是奥里诺科河，对吧？我想他去了那里。插图中给你的视角是雷利的视角。然后这个
was reissued in 1980. And the perspective is that of the people seeing Raleigh come. So you're seeing Raleigh through their eyes. In the illustration or in the text? Yeah, in the illustration. Right. In the illustration. Yeah.
在1980年再版了。视角变成了那些看着雷利到来的人。所以你是通过他们的眼睛看雷利。是在插图中还是在文字中？是的，在插图中。对。在插图中。是的。
And I guess that one of the things that probably has changed is that... So we're going to be talking to Satnam Sanghera about the British Empire in our next episode. But one of the things that I'm sure has changed is that a lot of Imperial history was couched in terms of adventure of British adventurers, be it Raleigh, be it Captain Cook,
我想可能发生变化的一点是……我们下一集将和Satnam Sanghera谈论大英帝国。但我敢肯定，发生变化的一点是，很多帝国历史都是以英国冒险家的冒险经历来表述的，无论是雷利，还是库克船长，
be it General Gordon or whoever, going off and having adventures. Yes. In exotic, far-flung places. Sort of the man who would be king style. The man who would be king. And obviously that's more complicated now. Yeah, it is. And I think that's actually a really interesting subject.
无论是戈登将军还是其他什么人，他们出去冒险。是的。在充满异国情调的遥远地方。有点像《那个想成为国王的人》那种风格。那个想成为国王的人。显然现在情况更复杂了。是的，确实。我认为这实际上是一个非常有趣的话题。
So a future book in this series, this Adventures in Time series, is going to be about the Conquistadors. And when we were talking about it, we had a big conversation about, you know, who's telling the story? Who are the heroes? Who are the, you know? And, you know, I felt, I mean, I haven't actually written it yet, so I'm just sort of jumping ahead, but I felt that the guys getting on the ships and going across has to be the start of the story
所以这个系列——《时间冒险》系列——未来的一本书将是关于征服者的。当我们谈论它时，我们进行了深入的讨论，你知道，谁在讲故事？谁是英雄？谁是……你知道的？而且，我觉得，我的意思是，我还没写出来，所以我只是有点超前了，但我认为那些登上船只并横渡大洋的人必须是故事的开始，
because to a child that is immediately... Did you not think, after talking to Camilla Townsend about the Aztecs, that actually the journey of the Aztecs from... Well, it is, but you don't have the sources to be able to tell it. But you kind of do. I don't think you do.
因为对孩子来说，这立刻就……在和Camilla Townsend谈论阿兹特克人之后，你难道不认为，实际上阿兹特克人的旅程从……嗯，确实是，但你没有足够的资料来讲述它。但你其实是有一些的。我不认为你有。
And I think the story of the Spaniards going on the ships, how many children's stories start with a voyage? I think that's a great story. But the Aztecs voyage. But I think then when they get there, you have to then give the perspective of the people to whom there's these bunch of weird bearded lunatics who pitched up from god knows where which you wouldn't have done or or it would have been much less likely
我认为西班牙人乘船前往的故事，有多少儿童故事是以航行开始的？我认为那是一个伟大的故事。但是阿兹特克人的航行。但我认为当他们到达那里时，你必须给出那些人的视角，对他们来说，这群不知从哪儿冒出来的奇怪的留胡子的疯子，如果你不这样做，或者在20或30年前这不太可能发生，
20 or 30 years ago so i think there's a way to reconcile adventure with multiple perspectives and um with a bit of nuance and and not telling it as a sort of purely moralistic adventure story. I mean, do you think, so we've got a question. Yes, from Theobald Tiger. Have to confess that H.E. Marshall, our island story, lit the spark for me. This is talking about 1955. At least she got the Canut story the right way round. I guess that's stopping the waves. A bit like Corporal Punishment, it didn't do any lasting harm, but I'd hardly recommend it today, but great illustrations. Yeah, that's funny. Actually, I mean, actually,
所以我认为有一种方法可以将冒险与多元视角结合起来，带有一点细微差别，而不是把它讲成一个纯粹的道德说教式的冒险故事。我的意思是，你认为……我们有一个问题。是的，来自Theobald Tiger。必须承认，H.E. Marshall的《我们的岛屿故事》点燃了我的火花。这是在说1955年。至少她把克努特大帝的故事讲对了。我想那是阻止海浪的故事。有点像体罚，它没有造成任何持久的伤害，但我现在很难推荐它，但插图很棒。是的，那很有趣。实际上，我的意思是，实际上，
Our Island Story is surprisingly progressive. There's quite a lot of stuff about, there's a woman writing it. I think she was from New Zealand. I think she slightly had an outsider's perspective. Yeah, Henrietta Marshall. Kind of the mainstream. But, you know, Our Island Story is kind of shorthand for a particular way of writing children's history
《我们的岛屿故事》出奇地进步。里面有很多内容，是一个女人写的。我想她是新西兰人。我想她稍微带有一种局外人的视角。是的，Henrietta Marshall。算是主流。但是，你知道，《我们的岛屿故事》是某种特定儿童历史写作方式的代名词，
that's rooted in a sense of, I guess, you know, the glories of British achievement. Yeah, I mean, I had a book that my grandparents gave me as a child. I think it used to be theirs. It was by somebody called Arthur Michael John, and it was published in, I think, I had a book that my grandparents gave me as a child. I think it used to be theirs. It was by somebody called Arthur Michael John, and it was published in, I think, 1902. And it was brilliant. I shouldn't say this, but it went through century by century.
它植根于一种，我想，你知道，英国成就的荣耀感。是的，我的意思是，我小时候祖父母给过我一本书。我想那曾经是他们的。作者叫Arthur Michael John，出版于，我想，我小时候祖父母给过我一本书。我想那曾经是他们的。作者叫Arthur Michael John，出版于，我想，1902年。它很棒。我不该这么说，但它是按世纪来写的。
At the end of each century, it said it had a chapter. Unfairly, it had a chapter called Great Men. And it just told you the 20 great men that you needed to know, you know. Were there any women? Never. There was never a woman. Boudicca, surely. I just told you the 20 great men that you needed to know, you know, Lord Salisbury. Never. There was never a woman. Boudicca, surely. And they really were all the sort of generals that are in Trafalgar Square.
在每个世纪末，它都有一章。不公平的是，它有一章叫“伟人”。它只是告诉你你需要知道的20个伟人，你知道。有女性吗？从来没有。从来没有女人。布狄卡，当然。我只是告诉你你需要知道的20个伟人，你知道，索尔兹伯里勋爵。从来没有。从来没有女人。布狄卡，当然。他们确实都是特拉法加广场上的那种将军。
I mean, it was – now, listen, I mean, I think history books always reflect their times. They do. But more than that, do they not reflect myths? So there's a kind of – in a sense, to make history accessible to children, you have to mythicise it to a degree. And the likelihood is that that myth will go with the grain of the broader national myth that is being propagated at the time. So our island story, the clue is in the word island. It's all about the Navy. It's all part of a continuous
我的意思是，它是——现在，听着，我的意思是，我认为历史书总是反映它们所处的时代。确实如此。但不仅如此，它们难道不反映神话吗？所以有一种——从某种意义上说，为了让儿童能够接触历史，你必须在一定程度上将其神话化。而这种神话很可能会顺应当时正在传播的更广泛的国家神话。所以《我们的岛屿故事》，线索就在“岛屿”这个词里。这全是关于海军的。这都是一个连续的
narrative but now we have new myths yes i guess we do i mean actually tom we had a lot of questions about this about how do you you know stories being distorted for children and all that stuff so the lady a good example of that is the oliver cromwell we talked about this with paul lay the oliver cromwell ladybird book starts with two stories that are just not true one of them is um he's stolen by a monkey as a boy and the other is the other that charles the first visits his house and they have a fight when they are sort of eight years old or something and those are the two facts about oliver cromwell that all children should learn but they're probably uppermost in my brain. I can't get rid of them. They're like floaters.
叙事，但现在我们有了新的神话。是的，我想我们有。我的意思是，实际上Tom，我们有很多关于这方面的问题，关于你如何，你知道，故事被为儿童扭曲等等。Ladybird书就是一个很好的例子，就是奥利弗·克伦威尔。我们和Paul Lay谈过这个，奥利弗·克伦威尔的Ladybird书以两个根本不是事实的故事开始，一个是，嗯，他小时候被猴子偷走了，另一个是查理一世访问他家，他们在八岁左右打了一架，而这些是所有孩子都应该了解的关于奥利弗·克伦威尔的两个事实，但它们可能在我脑海中占据了最重要的位置。我无法摆脱它们。它们就像飞蚊症一样。
But the thing is... I just can't flush them away. That, that, that, that. Those stories get a child interested in history. And you've got ample time to debunk them later. I mean, in the Second World War book, for example, I have a chapter about Dunkirk. Now, I could have gone in and said,
但问题是……我就是无法把它们冲走。那些，那些，那些，那些。那些故事让孩子对历史产生了兴趣。以后你有充足的时间去揭穿它们。我的意思是，在第二次世界大战那本书里，例如，我有一章关于敦刻尔克。现在，我本可以进去说，
the way to tell this story is to say there were some little ships involved, but they weren't as important as the big destroyers. And I just thought, who the hell is, what child, what sane person thinks that's the way to interest a child? The way to interest a child is to say, I'll take one little ship.
讲述这个故事的方法是说有一些小船参与了，但它们不如大驱逐舰重要。我只是想，谁会，什么样的孩子，什么样的理智的人会认为这是让孩子感兴趣的方法？让孩子感兴趣的方法是说，我选一艘小船。
It's basically the inspiration for the little ship in Dunkirk. It's a very famous story. It's a man called Charles Lightoller. He's retired. I think he's been on the Titanic. He's escaped. He's retired now. He's got this little boat that's his pride and joy.
它基本上是敦刻尔克那艘小船的灵感来源。这是一个非常著名的故事。那个人叫Charles Lightoller。他退休了。我想他上过泰坦尼克号。他逃出来了。他现在退休了。他有这艘小船，是他的骄傲和快乐。
He takes it across to Dunkirk. He fills it with all the men. They're under fire by the Germans. They escape planes shooting at them, and they get all the way back, and he unloads them. And it's just an incredibly heartening story, and it fits in with J.B. Priestley's stuff on the radio that he does a little later about the little ships.
他把它开到了敦刻尔克。他装满了所有的人。他们在德国人的炮火下。他们躲避向他们射击的飞机，他们一路返回，他把他们卸下来。这真是一个令人振奋的故事，它与J.B. Priestley后来在广播中讲的关于小船的内容很契合。
That is, to me, the obvious way to get a nine-year-old who maybe doesn't have a colossal amount of knowledge about history or great investments in history, to get them involved. And there's plenty of time later in life to debunk, to, you know, we had Roger Clarke talking about ghosts, didn't we? And he said in that, people always prefer the bunk to the debunk. And there's room for both, I think. Okay, well, on that note, question from Mikolaj Kishka.
对我来说，这是让一个九岁的孩子，也许对历史没有太多的了解，或者对历史没有太大的投入，让他们参与进来的显而易见的方法。以后的人生中有足够的时间去揭穿，去，你知道，我们有Roger Clarke谈论鬼魂，不是吗？他在那里面说，人们总是喜欢虚构胜过揭穿。我认为两者都有空间。好吧，说到这里，来自Mikolaj Kishka的问题。
Mikolaj. Mikolaj, sorry, Mikolaj. Is children's history always propaganda? No, I would say, because I think propaganda, my answer to that would be that propaganda only permits of one interpretation. I mean, that's why it is propaganda. Whereas I think you can write a children's history
Mikolaj。Mikolaj，抱歉，Mikolaj。儿童历史总是宣传吗？不，我会说，因为我认为宣传，我对这个问题的回答是，宣传只允许一种解释。我的意思是，这就是为什么它是宣传。而我认为你可以写一本儿童历史，
that has room for, that hints at disagreement or debate. So I wrote one book that's coming out before Christmas about Alexander the Great. And there's bits in that where I say, you know, some people said Alexander did this. Others said he did that. I think you have to give a sense of uncertainty from time to time. You know, some people thought Churchill was this.
它有空间，暗示分歧或辩论。所以我写了一本圣诞节前出版的关于亚历山大大帝的书。里面有一些片段我说，你知道，有些人说亚历山大做了这个。其他人说他做了那个。我认为你必须时不时地给人一种不确定感。你知道，有些人认为丘吉尔是这样。
Some people think Churchill was something else. And I think that makes it different from propaganda, to sort of say that the child can think, well, there are different views about this and maybe there isn't one right answer. Yeah, that's good. Yeah, yeah. But I think one thing that children do not give a damn about, and understandably, they don't give a damn
有些人认为丘吉尔是别的东西。我认为这使它不同于宣传，可以说孩子可以思考，嗯，关于这一点有不同的看法，也许没有一个正确的答案。是的，那很好。是的，是的。但我认为有一件事是孩子们根本不在乎的，而且可以理解，他们根本不在乎
about historiography. They don't really give a damn about sources. They just want to crack on and tell the story. That's one thing that's different from writing a novel. You need to make up your mind. It's a bit like being a newspaper economist, actually. You need to make up your mind and just go for it
史学。他们真的不在乎来源。他们只是想直接讲故事。这和写小说不同。你需要下定决心。实际上，这有点像做报纸经济学家。你需要下定决心，直接去做，
and tell one version of the story as much as possible. And you can have grey areas, but there's got to be a goodie. Well, just to give people a flavour from Dominic's book on Henry VIII, was he a mischievous, fun-loving little boy or a fat, greedy, brooding invalid? A sportsman, an art lover, a bully or a braggart? A strong ruler who stood up for England or a selfish tyrant who tore it apart? What's the answer? I think that that is the note on which to end, isn't it?
尽可能地讲述故事的一个版本。你可以有灰色地带，但必须有一个好人。好吧，只是为了让大家尝尝Dominic关于亨利八世的书的味道，他是一个淘气、爱玩的小男孩，还是一个肥胖、贪婪、阴郁的残疾人？一个运动员、艺术爱好者、恶霸还是吹牛大王？一个为英格兰挺身而出的强有力的统治者，还是一个将其撕裂的自私暴君？答案是什么？我认为这就是结束的基调，不是吗？
Leave that hanging. We're going to do an episode on Henry VIII fairly soon. You can give the answer to that. We are going to come up on that. But before we go, have you not promised one of our listeners that you will ask her a question? Oh, yes, I have. Yes, I have. Sorry.
把它悬在那里。我们很快会做一期关于亨利八世的节目。你可以给出那个答案。我们到时候会讲到。但在我们走之前，你不是答应过我们的一位听众你会问她一个问题吗？哦，是的，我答应过。是的，我答应过。抱歉。
Annie Scott. Annie, I hope you remember who it was who remembered your question. Yes. Not the person who had made the empty promise on Twitter, but the person who really cares about the evidence. Yes, I'm publicly shamed. Well, actually, the reason that I didn't ask this is because it's actually about history in schools it's a big topic but maybe we should enter the answer now so that annie gets her annie gets her and then we can come back to it later on so i think we're going to do a subject
Annie Scott。Annie，我希望你记得是谁记得你的问题。是的。不是那个在推特上做出空头承诺的人，而是真正关心证据的人。是的，我被公开羞辱了。好吧，实际上，我没有问这个的原因是因为它实际上是关于学校里的历史，这是一个大话题，但也许我们现在应该进入答案，这样Annie就能得到她的，Annie就能得到她的，然后我们以后可以再回来讨论它。所以我认为我们要讨论一个主题，
we're going to do a whole podcast on um history and education um but annie's question is um what history should be taught in school and should teachers of other subjects put their subject into its historical context hashtag typical teacher question but i promised he paul and tom promised he'd answer and i almost didn't so what history come on tom three things that we should do in schools oh i think the history of christianity the fall of the roman republic and obviously the Persian Wars. Yeah. See, my answer would be, I think probably we should do the last years of the, well, probably the first years of the 1970s. Yes.
我们要做一个关于历史和教育的完整播客，但Annie的问题是，学校应该教什么历史，其他学科的老师应该把他们的学科放在历史背景下吗？#典型的老师问题，但我答应过，Paul和Tom答应过他会回答，而我差点没回答。所以什么历史，来吧Tom，我们在学校应该做的三件事。哦，我认为是基督教的历史，罗马共和国的衰落，显然还有波斯战争。是的。你看，我的回答是，我想我们大概应该做20世纪70年代的最后几年，嗯，大概是1970年代的最初几年。是的。
The last years of the 1970s and the first years of the 1980s. No, I actually am going to answer it properly. I think people should do, everybody knows who's listened to this podcast that we both think children should learn about the 17th century because it's so pivotal. I think they should also learn about...
1970年代的最后几年和1980年代的最初几年。不，我实际上要正确地回答它。我认为人们应该做，听过这个播客的人都知道，我们俩都认为孩子们应该了解17世纪，因为它太关键了。我认为他们也应该了解……
But when you say children, what do you mean? I mean, what's the definition of a child? What age are we talking about? I think everyone knows what a child is. No, I don't. Because are you talking, you know, primary school? Well, that's a good question. First year of secondary school?
但当你说是孩子时，你是什么意思？我的意思是，孩子的定义是什么？我们说的是什么年龄？我想每个人都知道什么是孩子。不，我不知道。因为你在说，你知道，小学？嗯，这是一个好问题。中学一年级？
That's a really difficult question. Yeah, it's a very uh uh i think i think you're obviously you're talking about different things at different times aren't you you're talking yes smaller children that's why it's complicated it's all your attempt to try and yeah get this into a single quick answer okay so three things they should start they should do the romans yes obviously i think they should do the 17th century. Yes. And they should finish up by doing 20th century. Oh, 20th century what?
那是一个非常困难的问题。是的，这是一个非常……嗯，我想，我想你显然是在不同的时间谈论不同的事情，不是吗？你在谈论，是的，更小的孩子，这就是为什么它很复杂，这是你试图，是的，把这个变成一个单一的快速答案。好吧，所以他们应该做的三件事，他们应该做罗马人，是的，显然，我认为他们应该做17世纪。是的。他们应该以20世纪结束。哦，20世纪什么？
China? No, I think they should do maybe a smash with the World Wars and they should get into the Labour government of the mid-70s. The Jeremy Thorpe scandal. Yeah, the Jeremy Thorpe scandal, exactly. On the back of our colossally successful Jeremy Thorpe scandal yeah the Jeremy Thorpe scandal exactly on the back of our colossally successful Jeremy Thorpe podcast
中国？不，我想他们也许应该做一个世界大战的合集，他们应该进入70年代中期的工党政府。Jeremy Thorpe丑闻。是的，Jeremy Thorpe丑闻，完全正确。在我们极其成功的Jeremy Thorpe丑闻之后，是的，Jeremy Thorpe丑闻，完全正确，在我们极其成功的Jeremy Thorpe播客之后，
I think people will all be children I believe even now across Britain are queuing up to buy books about Rinker well on that bombshell
我想人们都会是孩子，我相信即使现在在英国各地，人们也在排队购买关于Rinker的书，好吧，就在那个重磅炸弹上，
great okay well I think we've sorted out now we can have a second stab now I'll let you finish the podcast well I mean I think I think that that our inability to answer that question in any way seriously shows that we do need an entire episode on history and education so we'll
太棒了，好吧，我想我们现在已经解决了，我们可以再试一次，现在我会让你结束播客。嗯，我的意思是，我想，我想我们无法以任何严肃的方式回答那个问题，这表明我们确实需要一整集关于历史和教育的节目，所以我们会
we'll stack that one up um and annie uh my huge apologies for almost forgetting you please do send us more questions when that topic comes up and i promise i'll wait that time around um but you should also plug the books one more time tom uh yeah so uh it's shocking that i have to remind you know dominic's got these adventure in time six wives of henry the eighth and the second world war yeah who cares it's not as if you've never plugged your own come on i do it slightly more subtly um well listeners will be the judge of that um and yeah so uh it's it's um there's a there's a lovely the almost the best bits in it are the author's note at the end um and i think that uh anyone wondering whether to get this for their child it's the very last um
我们会把那个堆起来，嗯，Annie，我非常抱歉差点忘了你，当那个话题出现时，请务必给我们发送更多问题，我保证我下次会等那个时候，但你也应该再推销一次书，Tom。嗯，是的，所以，嗯，Dominic有这些《时间冒险》系列，《亨利八世的六个妻子》和《第二次世界大战》，是的，谁在乎呢，又不是说你从来没推销过你自己的书，来吧，我推销得稍微含蓄一点，嗯，好吧，听众会做出判断的，嗯，是的，所以，嗯，它，嗯，里面几乎最好的部分是最后的作者注，我认为，任何想知道是否要为他们的孩子买这本书的人，这是最后，嗯，
paragraph in the um the book on the six wives of Henry VIII, Dominic's dedication to his son. Above all, thank you to Arthur, who read every chapter as I wrote it, solemnly ticking every battle, every massacre and every severed head and giving me extra points for hangings, drawings and quarterings. I could not have asked for a more enthusiastic or more bloodthirsty reader who would not want to read that. Thanks ever so much. Bye-bye. See you next time. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
段落，在关于亨利八世的六个妻子的书中，Dominic对他儿子的献词。最重要的是，感谢Arthur，他阅读了我写的每一章，庄严地勾选了每一场战斗、每一场屠杀和每一个被砍下的头颅，并为绞刑、拖刑和分尸给了我额外的分数。我不可能要求一个更热情或更嗜血的读者，谁不想读那个呢。非常感谢。再见。下次见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需奖励剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。那是restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。